you've been an outspoken proponent of
pro-life
um can you can we start by
you trying to steal man the case for
pro-choice that abortion is not murder
and uh a woman's right to choose is a
fundamental human right freedom so I
think that the the the only way to steal
man the pro-choice case is to
and be ideologically consistent
is to suggest that there is no interest
in the life of The Unborn
that counter weighs at all freedom of of
choice so the so what that means is
we can take the full example we can get
sort of the partial example so if we
take the full example what that would
mean is that up until point of birth
which is sort of the democratic party
platform position uh that there is that
a woman's right to choose ought to
extend for any reason whatsoever up to
point of birth the only way to argue
that is that bodily autonomy is the only
Factor there is no countervailing factor
that would ever outweigh bodily autonomy
um that that would be the the strongest
version of the argument another version
of that argument would be that the
reason that bottle of autonomy ought to
way so heavily is because women can't be
the well the equals of men if the this
Institutes of biology are allowed to
decide their Futures right if if the if
if pregnancy changes women in a way that
it doesn't change men it's a form of sex
discrimination for women to ever have to
go through with pregnancy which is an
argument that was made by Ruth Bader
Ginsburg kind of
um those are the arguments the the kind
of softer version is the more I would
say emotionally resonant version of the
argument which is that bodily autonomy
ought to outweigh the interests of the
fetus up till point x and then people
have different feelings about what point
x looks like is it up to the point of
viability is it up to the point of the
heartbeat is it up to 12 weeks or 15
weeks and that really is where the
American public is right where the
American public is broadly speaking not
not state by state where there are
various really really varied opinions
but like broadly speaking it seems like
the American public by pulling data one
somewhere between a 12 and 15 week
abortion restriction and they believe
that up until 12 or 15 weeks there's not
enough there for to not be specific but
to be kind of how people feel about it
to outweigh a woman's bodily autonomy
and then beyond that point then there's
enough of an interest in the life of the
pre-born child uh it's developed enough
then now we care about it enough that it
outweighs a woman's bodily autonomy
what's the strongest case for pro-life
in your mind I mean the strongest case
for pro-life is that from conception a
human life has been created it is a
human life with potential that human
life potential with potential now has an
independent interest in its own
existence if I may just uh ask a quick
question so conception is when a sperm
fertilizes an egg yes
okay just to clarify the biological
beginning of what concession means I
mean that because that is the beginning
of human life now there are other
standards that people have drawn right
some people say implantation in the
uterus some people will suggest
viabilities brain development or heart
development but the the clear dividing
line between a human life exists in
human life does not exist is the
biological creation of an independent
human life with its own DNA strands and
Etc which happens at concession
conception once you acknowledge that
there's that independent human life with
potential and I keep calling it that
because people sometimes say potential
human life it's not a potential human
life it's a human life that is not
developed yet to the full extent that it
will develop
once you say that and once you say that
it has its own interest now you have to
now the burden of proof is is to explain
why bodily autonomy
ought to allow for the snuffing out of
that human life if we believe that human
life ought not to be killed for for
quote unquote No Good Reason you have to
come up with a good reason right the
burden of proof has now shifted now you
will find people who will say well the
good reason is that it's not
sufficiently developed to outweigh the
mental trauma or emotional trauma that a
woman goes through if for example she
was raped or the victim of incest okay
and that that is a fairly emotionally
resonant argument but it's not
necessarily it's positive you can you
can make the argument that just because
something horrific and horrible happened
to a woman does not rob the human life
of its interest in life one of the big
problems in trying to draw any line for
the self-interest of life in the in the
human life is that it's very difficult
to draw any other line that doesn't seem
somewhat arbitrary and you say that
independent heartbeat you know well you
know people have pacemakers if you say
brain function people have various
levels of brain function as adults if
you say viability babies are not viable
after they are born if I left a newborn
baby on a table and did not take care of
it it would be dead in two days so you
know when once you start getting into
sort of these lines it starts to get
very fuzzy very quickly and so if you're
looking for sort of a bright line moral
rule
that would be the brightline moral Rule
and that's that's sort of the pro-life
case well there's still mysterious
difficult scientific questions of things
like consciousness
so what do you does the question of
consciousness
how does it come into play into this
debate so I don't believe that
Consciousness is the
sole Criterion by which we judge the
self-interest in human life
so
we are unconscious a good deal of Our
Lives
right that does not we will be conscious
again right when when you're unconscious
when you're asleep for example
presumably your life is still worth
living if somebody came in and killed
you that'd be a serious moral quandary
at the very least but the birth of
Consciousness the the lighting up of the
flame the initial lighting of the flame
there does seem to be something special
about that and it's a it's a mystery of
when that happens well I mean Peter
Cerner makes the case that basically
self-consciousness doesn't exist until
you're two and a half right so he says
that even infanticide should be okay
right he's the bioethicist over
Princeton so you're getting some real
dicey territory once you get into
Consciousness also the truth is the
Consciousness is more of a spectrum than
it is a than it is a a dividing line
meaning that there are people with
various degrees of brain function we
don't actually know how conscious they
are and you can get into eugenic
territory pretty quickly when we start
dividing between lives that are worth
living based on levels of consciousness
and lives that are not worth living
based on levels of consciousness do you
find it
the the aspect of uh women's freedom
do you feel the tension between the
ability to choose
the trajectory of your own life versus
um the the rights of the unborn child
in one situation yes in one situation
now if you've had
sex with a person voluntarily and as a
product of that you are now pregnant
no you've taken an action with a
perfectly predictable result even if you
took birth control this is the way that
human beings have procreated for
literally all of human existence and by
the way also how all mammals appropriate
so the idea that this was an entirely
unforeseen consequence of your activity
I find I I have less sympathy for you in
that particular situation because you
could have made decisions that would not
LED you to this particular impasse in
fact this used to be the basis of
marriage right was when when we were a
apparently more terrible Society we used
to say that people should wait until
they get married to have sex a position
that I still hold and the reason for
that was because then if you have sex
and you produce a child then the child
will grow up in a two-parent family with
stability so you know they they not not
a ton of sympathy there when it comes to
rape and incest obviously heavy heavy
sympathy and so that's why I think you
see statistically speaking a huge
percentage of Americans including many
pro-life Americans people who consider
themselves pro-life would consider
exceptions for rape and incest one of
the sort of dishonest things that I
think happens in abortion debates is
arguing from the fringes this tends to
happen is pro-choice activists will
argue from rape and incest to the other
99.8 percent of abortions or you'll see
people on the pro-life side argue from
partial birth abortion to all of
abortion that you actually have to take
on sort of the mainstream case and then
decide whether or not that's acceptable
or not but to you the exception just
ethically without generalizing it
um that is a valid ethically exception I
I don't hope that there should be a an
exception for rape or incest because
again I hold by the brightline rule that
once a human life with potential exists
then it has its own interest in life
that cannot be curbed by your
self-interest
um the the only exception that I hold by
is the same exception that literally all
pro-lifers hold by which is the life of
the mother is put in danger it's such a
tough tough topic because if you believe
that that's the line then we're
committing mass murder
well or at least Mass killing so I would
say that murder typically requires a
level of mens rea that may be absent in
many cases of abortion right this is
because the usual follow-on question is
we'll have to murder why not prosecute
the woman and the answer is because the
vast majority of people who are who are
having abortions don't actually believe
that they're killing a person
they they have a very different view of
what is exactly happening so you know I
would say that there are all sorts of
interesting hypotheticals that come in
to play when it comes to abortion and uh
you can play them any which way
um but
levels it let's put it this way there
are gradations of wrongs I don't think
that all abortions are equally
blameworthy even if I would even if I
would ban
virtually all of them right okay I think
that they're mitigating circumstances
that make while being wrong some
abortions less morally blameworthy than
others I think that you know there there
is a I can admit a difference between
killing a a two-week-old embryo in the
womb and stabbing a seven-year-old in
the face like I can I can recognize all
that while still saying I think that it
would be wrong to terminate a pregnancy
do you think the question of One Life
Begins which I think is a fascinating
question
um is the question of science or a
question of religion I mean One Life
Begins it's a question of science when
when that life becomes valuable enough
for people to want to protect it uh is
is going to be a question that is beyond
science science doesn't have moral
judgments to make about the value of
human life this is one of the problems
that Sam Harris and I've had this
argument many times and it's always kind
of interesting you know because Sam is
of the opinion that you can get to Art
From is right that science says is
therefore we can learn odd so human
flourishing is the goal of life and I
always say to him I don't see where you
get that from evolutionary biology you
can you can you can assume it just say
you're assuming it but don't pretend
that that is a conclusion that you can
draw straight from
biological reality itself because
obviously that doesn't exist in the
animal world for example nobody assumes
the innate value of every ant